We're gonna talk about monasticism today,
uh,
and um,
monasticism in the popular imagination and accurately is linked to learning.
We all have this image of,
you know,
monks quietly copying manuscripts,
uh,
and those manuscripts being,
how the learning of the ancient world was transmitted.
We're going to talk a little more about that when we come to the near the end of
the course on intellectuals in the court of Charlemagne,
but monasticism and learning our linkedin our mind,
but they are not intrinsically linked.
There is no logical reason why monks should copy manuscripts.
They should pray.
They should live in some kind of a renunciation of the world.
Uh,
generally speaking in the medieval west,
they live in communities,
generally speaking.
They're engaged in a kind of corporate rather than individual prayer.
All of these things follow from the way monasticism was conceived and the major
text though not the only one,
but the most influential text about how monasticism was conceived is the sixth
century rule of Saint Benedict.
The rule of saint benedict has some possible references to sacred reading as it
calls it,
or to some kind of a program of knowledge.
It assumes that the monks are literate,
for example,
a lot to assume at the time.
But no,
where does benedict say police preserve the classical tradition by,
uh,
being scribes and writing in the scriptorium?
So how does this come about?
Is One of the problems,
uh,
that we will deal with.
But what we're really interested is monasticism without the learning.
And the reason we're interested in that is not only is this the prevailing
spiritual movement of the early Middle Ages,
but it has a tremendous influence on society outside the monastic walls.
Because central to our discussion is a paradox.
The paradox is that while the monks are trying to escape the world,
the world is following them.
The world is very interested in their prayers because their prayers are thought
to have a powerful real world.
This world effect.
So as the monks become more distant from society,
God hears their prayers with more and more sympathy.
Therefore,
their prayers have a kind of power,
uh,
power to benefit others.
This notion of power is like some kind of a,
you know,
almost electrical utility.
They're building up an incredible amount of electricity,
if you want to call it that,
or let's say spiritual energy to be more accurate,
way more than they need,
way more than they can consume.
You know,
they're there like some little,
a
Persian Gulf state that is producing 10% of the world's oil.
There's no way they can use all of that.
Um,
in this case then,
how does the surplus get distributed?
It gets distributed through the generosity of people outside the world,
worried about the condition of their souls.
The notion that I,
possessor of spiritual reserves and spiritual power can pray for you.
Sinful night,
sinful king,
sinful merchant is called intercession
notion that I can intercede for you.
And we've already seen this,
haven't we?
We've seen this with the saints in Gregory of tour and in other texts we tried
to emphasize how important the saints are,
not just for our understanding of medieval religion,
but for an our understanding of medieval society member that I tried to
emphasize that one of the problems once you're done with the Roman Empire is how
society is held together in the Roman Empire.
It's pretty clear.
It's held together by institutions that are known though not the same of our as
our own are translatable to our own law,
administrative structure,
land holding the whole panoply of,
uh,
what passes for civilized life.
But in the early Middle Ages,
after the collapse of the Roman Empire,
Oh,
we've seen the society does not have as much literacy,
does not have very good records of the kings are thugs.
Uh,
the political order is very unstable.
There's an awful lot of warfare.
There's a lot of this order.
You can't just dial nine one one and expect a response.
So the question then becomes what holds that society together?
And we mentioned some things including the church.
And here we're looking at a particular instance of how that works because the
monks far from being kind of out there in the forest or a desert or some remote
region,
or even if they are in the forest or desert and some remote region are extremely
important to how society functions.
Because this is a society in which the spiritual,
the military,
the political,
the economic are not easily conceptually separated.
This is the Middle Ages.
Okay?
Do you love the Middle Ages?
Otherwise we wouldn't be here together,
but this is the part of the Middle Ages,
um,
that is perhaps most medieval.
What could be more meaningful than monasticism?
When I started teaching,
which wasn't that long after the Middle Ages,
but when I started teaching monasticism was a real problem because it was so
alien.
What are these?
What are these people doing?
In a way,
the situation is better because monasticism is sort of chic,
at least temporary.
We can monasticism.
People think of monasteries,
sort of like spa and you go there to get cleansed.
In fact,
a lot of monasteries have taken on a lot of new business with retreats and
detoxification and pilgrimage and these kinds of concepts.
But at the same time,
while I think we understand the desire to renounce the world,
or to take time off from the world,
or to,
you know,
leave the personal digital devices at home and think about something for more
than three seconds at a time,
um,
all of this is temporary.
The whole point of detoxification is that you then go and you know,
uh,
retox sify yourself or normal,
you know,
go back to normal life.
Uh,
what we have to understand here are people who have decided to,
uh,
embrace a world renouncing way of life for good.
Now,
monks,
therefore our clergy,
they are members of the professional members of the church,
but they're not priests.
It's key that you understand the difference.
Priests interact with the Laity.
Laymen Laity are people who are ordinary people,
believers,
but not clergy,
okay?
The priests interact with the laity through a mass,
The performance of the sacraments,
things like baptism little bit later than this period.
Confession,
okay.
Um,
anointment of the sick.
These are things in which the sacred is conveyed from the spiritual world to lay
people via priests.
Priests are in that sense,
the intermediaries between the divine and the material,
but because priests are involved in the world,
there are certain aspects of their differentiation from the world and there's a
lot of debate in the church at various times over whether that includes
celibacy,
not getting in the era that we're dealing with.
There are married priests or there are priests who are more or less married.
Uh,
and then there are pre sewer Sullivan,
but monks are not supposed to interact with the world.
They are leading a life of contemplation and self denial.
True.
They cannot focus only on their own salvation because that would've been
ignoring the Christian's duty to others.
One of the problems about being a contemplative in the Christian tradition is as
soon as you say something like,
boy,
I am really contemplating great today.
Or,
wow,
I am really seeing the mysteries of the universe.
Or,
I can't believe I haven't had anything to eat or drink for three days and I'm
feeling great.
Your you are falling off,
you're falling away,
you're selfish,
you're taking pride in your own accomplishments.
So from the beginning is the notion that,
um,
the monks have to abandon everything,
including self satisfaction.
In fact,
even most importantly,
self satisfaction.
And this is where Benedict's notion of humility comes from cause very strong in
the rule of Saint Benedict.
Okay.
Where does this desire to rid oneself of the world come from?
It's very strong in Christianity.
It's all over the new testament.
That is actually part of the Christian message.
It's,
it's awkward because most people don't follow that,
including most people who are believers.
They don't in fact give away everything,
may have to the poor and follow Christ.
Um,
you know,
they don't renounce,
uh,
the,
pleasures of life,
of the flesh and so forth.
But that is sort of what they are telling you to do.
The first monk,
the first guy who,
um,
we know of to decide to run away to the desert and lead a life of contemplation
is Saint Anthony of Egypt.
While Anthony,
you know how to spell that,
he lived from two 51 to three 56.
I have trouble believing this.
The sources are pretty good.
I a trouble believing that anybody could live to be 105 in the Roman empire or
indeed a at anytime before 10 years ago or so.
Uh,
but there it is.
Um,
at least we know that in two,
seven day he heard the saying of Jesus in a church,
go sell all you have,
give to the poor and follow me.
And he followed this literally he established as a solitary hermit in Egypt.
An Egypt is a great place for monasticism because Egypt has a very narrow strip
of incredibly fertile land on either side of the Nile,
the Nile,
which until the building of the Aswan dam flooded every year and it's silt that
it brought down from it's sources was so rich that it created this marvelous
soil on which all sorts of things could grow.
But once you got beyond that limit,
you were in the desert.
So you have absolute and total release,
you know,
kind of Sahara,
like desert,
very close to fertile land,
the best land of the Mediterranean so that you could have a kind of interaction
between,
I mean it's not like you decide that you want to be a hermit and you live in
Manhattan and you drive in,
you drive and you drive and you know,
you're just looking at them on an island and you're in the suburbs and then
you're in the excerpts and then you're in sort of gas stations and strip malls
and then you're in the Hamptons.
You know,
it's very,
very hard.
I mean you can actually,
if you go north,
pretty soon you'll get,
if not hermit country,
at least,
um,
a decent,
uh,
isolation.
Of course,
the problem with New York is it's really cold.
It's great to be a hermit in a,
you know,
September.
But,
uh,
the Adirondack hermitage is present problems in the winter.
Uh,
Egypt is hot.
All right,
but certainly no,
um,
uh,
exposure to cold problem anyway,
the first monks are in Egypt and they're known as the desert fathers.
Often they live alone as hermits,
but sometimes they live in communities.
They have their own cells in these communities,
but they can come together for prayer or for some sort of spiritual
companionship.
What's interesting is that right from the start,
these hermits or first monks appealed to the people who had no plans to become
monks.
They appealed to the people of the cities of Alexandria or thieves,
et Cetera of Egypt.
The reason is,
and the reason why people would become monks is the establishment of the church
as the official Church of the Roman Empire.
There are no monks in the first years of Christianity because just being a
Christian means denying the world the threat of death at the hands of the Roman
authorities.
Uh,
and the illegality of the religion means that you are already in a world
renouncing position.
But once the church becomes established,
once all sorts of people start joining it for motives that have nothing to do
with spiritual reasons or maybe 10% spiritual 90%,
and it's time my career,
uh,
you know,
I want my kids to grow up in the sorta right faith then those of real spiritual
bent devotion desire half to present themselves as more than merely attending
church as serious about Christianity in some sense.
So monasticism has to be understood in its earliest years as a reaction against
the compromises and comfort of official Christianity.
And
we see this in Augustine's confessions where you will recall the emotional
crisis that finally tipped Augustine over the edge into his conversion
experience,
was hearing about the monks of Egypt from someone who had come to Milan and had
been in Egypt and described these men and actually women who were not well
educated.
We're certainly not trained in rhetoric law and the classics to the extent of
Augustine.
Yet nevertheless,
they had,
in Augustine's words,
stormed the gates of heaven.
They had by their spiritual renunciation,
hence their spiritual power become close to God in ways that he Augustine and
his friends with all their knowledge had not.
And this contrast is what decides Augustine to embrace a way of life.
That although not monastic and much more active in the world is a renunciation
of the standard career,
the standard definitions of success in the Roman Empire and involvement in the
world in things like marriage,
property owning,
et cetera.
So in fact,
if the monks are these not very well educated people,
if embracing their values means giving up Cicero and the,
uh,
classical tradition,
it looks as if monasticism isn't anti intellectual movement.
And come back to this paradox of the monks as custodians of learning.
It's not quite the Fox as the protector of the hands,
but it is,
um,
uh,
it is not automatic that the monks would find themselves in the position of
copying down Cicero.
So the first forms of monasticism are those of the Egyptian desert.
There's a kind of tension from the start between a septic individualism and
collective monasticism.
Ascetic individualism means one person engaging in practices that dramatize the
renunciation of the world.
A classic example is not from Egypt,
but from Syria.
These are the saints who sit on top of pillars for decades at a time.
Individual,
right?
Beth are there.
They're alone on this pillar.
You know,
maybe it's this wide or maybe this wide at the top.
Um,
30 feet,
high,
50 feet high.
These saints collectively are known as stylized.
He's a stylized is a pillar and the most famous of them,
Saint Simon of the desert or Saint Simon ladies
lived on top of this pillar four,
what is it,
35 years,
something like that.
35 years up there in the rain,
in the sun.
Imagine the sanitary or range.
Imagine this.
I mean,
this is world renunciation,
but he was not alone.
He was alone on top of the pillar.
He was a hermit,
but people came and visited him.
There are pictures of ladders going up to him,
people climbing these ladders,
sometimes delivering the little message.
Would you pray for my child who was dying of,
uh,
well,
I don't know what he's dying off,
you know,
or,
uh,
um,
asking for things,
uh,
in the world.
Please deliver me from a bankruptcy.
Please deliver me from illness.
Um,
please protect me on this voyage.
Why don't they ask God themselves?
Okay.
Save a trip to the desert out of Antioch.
Save perhaps a donation to the Saint Simon.
Stay Ladies Foundation
because God is going to listen to Simon Ryan.
Why
he's worthy to speak to them
and why is he worthy?
What does he done to make himself worthy or you're quite right.
He's renounced the world and he knows what
he's not unbelievably cultivated.
Probably Syriac in this case,
probably those notes are in Syriac,
but um,
okay.
His world renunciation has imbued him with power.
This is not unique to Christianity,
right?
Shamanism.
The idea of a,
uh,
person who is an outcast in society or who has renounced the normal comforts of
society,
what's the problem with just getting married,
having kids,
having a job,
wondering what's for dinner
from the Christian point of view,
that's what most practitioners are doing.
Focusing on the world.
You have to focus on the world.
Supposing you wake up one morning and say,
I'm going to be a much more spiritual person and then you know,
there's whaling from your kids and your spouse a is nagging you about fixing the
dripping faucet.
I mean,
this is stuff you've got to look forward to.
Most of you,
I don't expect you to go into monasteries.
Uh,
but um,
this is a distraction from what the New Testament tells you to do.
The New Testament doesn't say go ahead,
be happy,
amass property,
get a great job,
make a lot of contacts,
get ahead,
have bunches of children,
uh,
get them into good schools,
you know,
get them coaches for the sats and,
and so forth.
And so what,
um,
if you have done that because you know,
you just got trapped,
you just,
well,
one thing led to another and here you are if so far is you have spiritual
anxieties and desires,
then you're going to want to have a patron.
You're gonna want to have someone who can intervene with you just like way back
when you had somebody write a letter of recommendation because they were on the
board of some,
a company or they uh,
um,
you know,
they had some influence here.
Your patron is a spiritual patron and it is monks or hermits.
So the role of the holy man in society is of somebody who has a heroic ability
denied to most ordinary people.
This is a spiritual superhero who like comic books.
Superheroes isn't just a superhero for his own benefit.
It doesn't just fly around cause he likes the sensation of flying around.
But who helps those who are weaker than him
and the intervention of somebody on here,
very important.
St like Simon stylized,
he's transcended the merely curative.
Simon was without fear of the emperor,
for example.
What could the emperor due to him that was worse than living at the top of the
pillar are after all,
um,
the emperor Constantz yes,
one of the sons of Constantine in the early fourth century was going to punish
the city of Antioch for defying.
Um,
the tax collectors tax had been collected in Antioch.
There had been a riot.
Lots of people were killed.
Normally you'd expect,
uh,
the wrath of the emperor to come down on this city and punish it very severely.
Simon was able to intervene with Konstanz just to prevent this from happening.
Constantio is listened to him because he was a little scared of him.
People are a little scared of those who are not only not playing the game,
but who are,
um,
playing a different game according to unique and very difficult to imitate
rules.
So there's a paradox here.
Again,
as the withdrawal from society becomes more dramatic,
the imputed spiritual power becomes greater.
If Simon's renunciation we're limited to something kind of like,
um,
small,
uh,
I,
I'm,
you know,
suppose he became a Vegan,
uh,
would people believe in his power?
And then this brings up the question of then,
what is the power of the rule of Saint Benedict?
If you read the rule of Saint Benedict,
there's nothing in there about living outdoors all the time.
At the top of a pillar,
there's nothing about extreme asceticism yet benedictine monasticism would prove
more durable than pillar sitting.
It would prove more durable than the deserts saints,
even
monasticism was brought to the West in several forms.
But generally speaking,
although there are lots of hermits,
we hear more about the communities of monks.
Monks who live in an establishment
and beginning in the sixth,
late sixth and particularly in the seventh century,
a lot of monasteries were established in rural parts of Europe,
rural or small town parts of Europe,
places like Saint Alban's in England,
which is not far from London or beads,
monastery of Gero in North Umbria,
more remote or folder
in the,
in Germany,
uh,
right canal,
a monastery in south western Germany on a little island in like con stones.
These monasteries owned property and indeed many of them became very rich
because one way of affiliating yourself with the monastery was to give to them
to donate land,
money,
serfs,
coins,
booty,
whatever.
And the reason people donate it is because of the violence of their lives.
The people who had the stuff to donate usually had gotten it by violence because
it's a society that as you've seen in the pages of Gregory of tour particularly,
but not exclusively.
It is a society organized around warfare.
All of these guys in Gregory of tour have blood on their hands.
You cannot be successful without a certain amount of the infliction of pain on
other people.
And although the rich and wealthy in any society do not believe themselves to
be,
um,
rich and wealthy for a vicious reasons,
indeed the rich and wealthy generally speaking,
think they're great in this society.
The rich and wealthy think they're great.
All right,
but they're also very anxious.
Uh,
it's not just a question of,
you know,
what is the phrase that's often used by donors to universities?
Um,
give back to Yale,
for example,
or give back to society.
It's not just a question of giving back to society.
Yes,
I made $40 billion.
So I feel I need to give back something.
It's a question of,
um,
I'm going to hell at what can I do?
I know I'm going to hell because,
um,
you know,
I killed 80 people in the course of just,
business deals or the closing of this deal required the 10 people be killed,
um,
or you know,
500 or 2000.
So there is a symbiosis to be cynical about it.
And as you know,
I'm not really very cynical person.
I hope that has come through hope it's come through that and I'm really
idealistic,
even naive.
Um,
but if you'll forgive a moment of cynicism,
there is a symbiosis between the monks who are amassing this huge quantity of
spiritual energy and the leaders of society who are amassing this huge quantity
of sins.
It's a natural trade agreement.
So there are paradoxical consequences of monastic wealth.
As these places get richer and richer,
uh,
they become too important to the kings,
the leaders of society,
just to be left to a bunch of weird world renouncing hermits.
They start to be,
um,
administered by people who themselves are from high families of high lineage in
order to become a monk add folder or rationale.
And you can't just wander in and say,
I'm renouncing the world.
You've got to be,
uh,
from a good family.
Got to come with an endowment.
Generally speaking,
to get into Ryka now as a month,
the family's going to have to pay a huge amount of property money,
some form of wealth that endows that mom.
Okay.
So at some point maybe people will stop believing that Reichi now is such a
great place.
Maybe they'll stop believing in its spiritual energy.
This would happen later,
but uh,
not yet.
Not yet.
They,
the preservation of the monasteries and their growth and success is due to the
rule of Saint Benedict,
the most important development of western monasticism and that there are all
kinds of other monasticism in the Christian world.
But the monasticism that would characterize western Europe is the rule of Saint
Benedict,
late sixth century,
who devised a set of regulations for communal monasticism.
So the rule of think benedict is a manual for the monastic life.
How to set up and run a monastery.
It's not the first,
it's based on an older a rule.
Uh,
we don't have to go into sort of who is responsible for inventing benedictine
monasticism as it's called,
but the monasteries of the West would be,
for the most part,
Benedictine until the 12th century.
When you start to have other orders that is,
there would be thousands of monasteries throughout Europe and they would follow
more or less the rule that you have read.
Why is this rule so successful?
For one thing,
it is moderate.
It is reproducible on a large scale.
It is ascetic.
All right?
It does involve giving up a lot of things,
but not to an extreme,
not to be compared to the life of a desert hermit or a desert pillar sitter or
the harsh monasticism of the Irish tradition.
You don't have to go to some little island that's,
you know,
one square kilometer large and out in the middle of the Windy Irish Sea,
uh,
and build some little beehive hot and live their
aesthetic.
Monasticism of the extreme sword is all over the place because hostile
environments are all over the place.
Now.
It's not as if benedictine monasteries are all located in cure,
full Hillary fertile countryside,
but a lot of them are,
a lot of them are located in,
uh,
um,
productive land,
but more than that,
they require,
yeah,
a certain kind of a set of CISM.
The asceticism of a Benedictine monotonous monastery is renunciation of self in
favor of the community.
In that sense,
it's almost a,
um,
an opposite of the kind of monasticism that hermits or pillar saints practice.
Okay.
What is acidic about a Benedictine monastery is not only the celibacy part or
the prayer part or the isolation from worldly stimulus part,
but the fact that you're not alone most of the time.
Yeah.
You have to subordinate your will to communal rituals and life.
You have to subordinate your will to the Abbot.
Remember how much benedict emphasizes obedience.
This is not just a good management tool for making it clear who's in charge.
It is a form of self abnegation,
a form of renunciation.
Benedict also
enjoins manual labor.
This is a penitential tool,
but it's also something that has perhaps something to do with the economic
success of these founders.
These are monks who are engaged in primarily two activities.
Labor and prayer.
Prayer we'll talk about in a moment and it's quite understandable,
but labor is more interesting and innovative because the ancient world despised
labor.
The whole idea of how you should live in preconversion Augustine's opinion,
which reflects that of late Roman society is what was called,
um,
leisure with dignity.
Leisure with dignity is what most professors aspire to.
That is to say,
um,
leisure,
but not just to take naps and you know,
uh,
play with your dog or uh,
you know,
surf various dubious sites on the Internet,
uh,
leisure it to read,
to think,
to engage in a kind of genteel contemplation.
And this is the ideal of those Roman senators who are,
you know,
writing philosophical dialogues.
Okay.
But work actual work is degrading,
horrible in the ancient world not to be engaged in by anybody who could call
himself a gentleman.
So by making people work,
including people who come from the upper classes.
This is a penitential Labor indeep can we labor with your hands though?
Other kinds of labor were envisaged a in section 48 benedict talks about labor
and sacred reading and this is one of those places where you can draw out from
its meaning that copying manuscripts as a form of labor reading texts is a form
of labor.
Okay,
so the transformation or at least the addition of learning as part of the
mission statement of monasteries is implicit here,
but certainly not drawn out by Benetech
prayer.
One of the things that is involved in this surrendering of your will to the
greater communal good is the performance of prayers.
Benedict emphasizes humility.
Okay.
The monk's life as a ladder of humility,
humility is encouraged by obedience.
Yeah.
Silence.
In Benedictine monasteries,
you weren't silent all the time,
but there is a discouragement against mirror chatter,
labor.
All of these are penitential activities in which the individual will is
suppressed.
And if you think of experiences in which the individual will is suppressed so
that the person focuses on the community.
We are all familiar.
In fact,
you are more familiar than I am probably more immediately with such activities.
Um,
any kind of training or boot camp like thing or uh,
you know,
I'm a senior society or um,
an acapella group makes you do stuff with the group that may be unpleasant,
difficult self sacrificing,
but that reinforces the Esprit de Corps.
This is the heart of the military.
Military beats you up in order to make you focus on the group and many other
organizations,
including businesses,
you know,
the,
this idea of going out into the mountains and uh,
um,
you know,
turning you loose with a tent and some rope,
uh,
and seeing which groups are able to survive or you know,
whatever they do.
Um,
this is part of this kind of training.
It's not just to train you into,
depending on other people.
It's to train you into focusing on the success of the organization or group as
opposed to your own aggrandizement.
But a difference again is you come back from the little,
uh,
upward bound experience where you come back from the retreat or you come back
from the scavenger hunt.
In this case,
this is your life.
But in addition to obedience,
labor,
silence,
prayer is the most important renunciatory activity.
Cause these are not just prayers.
Like,
okay,
I'm going to go in for five minutes and recite some prayers.
These are prayers that go on all day with some breaks.
One of the psalms seems to suggest that you should make,
um,
prayers,
uh,
seven times a day.
Okay?
So they begin a little bit after midnight,
let me go to sleep for a little while and then they get up a little before dawn.
They pray and then they go back to sleep for a little while and then they have,
uh,
a kind of early morning session and so forth and so on,
seven times a day.
And these are prayers that go through the psalms.
Primarily
different monasteries have different liturgies.
A liturgy is a kind of ritual cycle.
Some monasteries have more prayer and less contemplation or less prayer and more
work,
but they all are engaged in the performance of group prayers,
not individual,
but the community.
And these go on and on and on and they take on a kind of rhythm or a monotony or
a kind of visionary power that such experiences can convey.
And it is these prayers better what are really storing up those spiritual
reserves I was talking about as characteristic of monastery there,
this tremendous power that all of these repeated prayers have that cannot be
duplicated outside the walls of the monastery.
So this heavy round of prayer involves a significant sacrifice of comfort and of
the self.
This is a kind of sleep deprivation amongst never really quite make up.
The sleep deficiencies is they sort of stagger into a Mastin's as one the first
hours or called or lauds the pre sunrise hour.
But this is very impressive to the outside world,
the outside world.
The donors love this.
They love the buildup of these prayers and they will like the prayers to take
place in a nice space rather than having the monastery church being some kind
of,
you know,
Dank,
uh,
or a fire trap wooden structure.
They'll build beautiful churches for them and beautiful dormitories for them as
well and beautiful refractories for them.
If you're a donor,
you would rather that the stuff that you're donating for take place in Nice
surroundings.
Donors like it.
If the lawns at Yale are well clipped.
Ryan and,
and I think I've said this before,
the closest thing to a monastery is a college
with some obvious differences,
but communal living.
The quadrangle is like the cloister,
uh,
focused in on itself.
Um,
the emphasis on the group identification with the institution,
uh,
the notion that your activities will benefit society,
not so much your prayers,
but all that great research were allegedly doing.
Um,
are you okay?
The parallel does not,
uh,
carry,
perfectly,
but it is no accident that this university looks a little bit like a monastery
is to evoke a tradition of contemplation.
Isolation.
People speak about the Yale bubble,
but it's supposed to be a bit of a bubble.
It was constructed that way.
That is the ideal.
Now,
you may not have chosen to go to the places that really,
uh,
reproduce the,
um,
the monastic ideal.
Oh,
I went to the University of California at Santa Cruz.
Uh,
you know,
it was like up on a hill in a redwood forest that was sort of like a monastery
or Irlam college and you know,
in Indiana or Marlboro College in Vermont.
Right?
I know you rejected these places.
I know you just laughed at them just thinking about going to them,
but their heart,
people who have decided to go,
no
devastated that you didn't get into or alum.
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
but this is an American ideal that is similar
to the monastic ideal.
It is a sort of renunciatory ideal and is an ideal of learning.
So how do we get to learning in the last few minutes?
I just want to trace these connections.
The Benedictine rule,
as you will have noticed,
does not encourage learning.
And Benedict himself did not regard this as a primary duty of monks.
He did expect the monks to read the Bible.
He expected them to listen to readings from the church fathers and very key.
He says that the monks should take out a book from what he calls the Biblioteca.
Biblioteca is the Latin word for library.
It's not clear when monasteries had libraries,
but really the idea of collecting books and copying them comes from a late Roman
culture from a desire to understand the Bible.
Okay.
And from a transformation of that world of cultivated leisure wear,
the intellectuals like Augustine and his mentors were the custodians of learning
to a world in which the clergy,
and particularly the monastic clergy,
were the custodians of learning because the monks had two key,
three key elements.
They had learning that as they were literate,
they had time.
Even though the prayers consumed a lot,
they're not in the world and they had wealth.
It's not inevitable that time learning and wealth should lead to a cultural
efflorescence,
but they are certainly favorable conditions.
Okay,
so I leave you with that implication of the rule.
We will develop it further in a few weeks.
What we're going to be talking about beginning on Monday of next week is Islam.
So we are moving into a different post Rome
reality.
Thanks.